I can't tell you what a treat it is for
me personally to welcome Paul Krugman
back to Yale Paul is a Yale graduate
class of 1974 he went off and did his
PhD a near-record time at MIT and
returned to Yale in 1977 to join the
economics department faculty for the
all-too-brief period of two years but
let me tell you I've at that point I got
my degree on my PhD from the Economics
Department in 1974 the same year that
Paul left to go to graduate school but
when he came back we had offices next
door or we couldn't remember his next
door across the hall and the in the on
the third floor of 28th Hillhouse Avenue
it was pretty it was pretty seedy then
and it's still pretty seedy Paul
remembered the bathtub in his office and
I reminder of was across the hall but it
was it was not the greatest
accommodations but we we had a very
lively time and this was exactly the
period in Paul's career where he was
working out the ideas that led to his
Nobel Prize the the the notion of
integrating the some of the theoretical
ideas from industrial organization
economics into the the international
trade framework of comparative advantage
these were brilliant papers beautiful
and simple and and not so technically
sophisticated that you know any graduate
student even any undergraduate could
easily understand the basic idea
extraordinary pieces of work and I
remember many conversations at the time
since I was the inner the industrial
organization guy that Paul had next door
to talk to as he as he sort of worked
toward this this synthesis and it was a
remarkable experience for me to see such
a creative and
innovative young economist doing such
powerful and important work and so none
of us Yale had we're at least bit
surprised we were disappointed to lose
him back to MIT in 1979 but none of us
were surprised when years later he first
got the John Bates Clark medal for
distinguished contributions in economics
for economists under the age of 40 and
then subsequently won the Nobel Prize
for an entire body of work that's the
the the is impressed makes impressive
contributions to the understanding of
international trade and Finance Paul has
gone on whilst taking academic positions
at Stanford and and and Princeton where
it currently is as well as MIT and Yale
where he'd been before and continue to
be active in for many years in research
in recent years of course we all know
him as you know the person whose column
we read first when we turned to the
op-ed pages the New York Times as a
person who's vigorous and you'll and
lucid prose enlightens us about the
state of the world and contemporary
contemporary economics and the politics
of contemporary economics you know Paul
writes with a sharpness that put things
into very clear very clear relief he
writes from a perspective that we were
just talking we both recognized as the
perspective of what in in our day when
we were students was known to be kind of
the Yale MIT axis on macroeconomics and
monetary policy a wisdom that
unfortunately got forgotten for for 20
years or so during the during the period
actually more than 20 years from the
Reagan years until the until the great
crisis of 2008 a wisdom that we're
relearning
thanks very much to Paul's own very
lucid writing and exquisite and
exposition of key ideas about what's the
appropriate mix of monetary and fiscal
policy in a crisis what what is the you
know
what can and what can't monetary policy
actually accomplished and and not to
mention all of his other work on other
important aspects of economic and social
policy is strong position on health care
and so forth I'm not gonna take a
position I will certainly take a
position on the monetary and fiscal
stuff which I think he has been in
hundred-percent on the mark in pointing
out important important pitfalls in the
kind of thinking that's dominated
macroeconomic policy for the last three
decades I think we're gonna see a change
as we often do after deep recessions and
more intelligent that recognize that
things can indeed go wrong in it are
ways to fix the things that go wrong
anyway enough about my ideas we're
delighted to have Paul back and we
wanted to make do something a little
special and not just have him speak to
you but actually recognize from Yale's
perspective this contribution of this
extraordinary distinguished alumnus of
Yale College and so we have we have our
own medal to give a howlin Memorial
Prize was established in 1915 by Charles
Holland who was a graduate of Yale
College 1891 and Francis Holland and
John Holland eighteen graduate of 1894
to honor their father who was a Yale BA
from 1854 and a fellow of the Yale
Corporation and the prizes according to
the citation awarded to a citizen of any
country and recognition of some
achievement of marked distinction in the
field of literature fine arts or the
theory of government or policy well I
think Paul Krugman's work on political
economy over the last decade in the new
york times not to mention his scholarly
work qualifies easily as extraordinary
achievement of mark distinction in in
the theory of government or politics
he's been he's illuminated so many of us
and helped us to think in important and
critical ways about the key issues
times another it was in there in the
letter that company the gift to Yale
from the Howland family it indicated
that an important factor in the
selection and I quote shall be the
idealistic element in the recipients
work and I think it's great to see in
someone to Paul's advanced standing in
the profession of economics and in the
public eye that continued that continued
sense of idealism and and hope for the
future of this country
this prize has been awarded to
distinguished composers distinguished
writers and artists and distinguished
statesman among the recipients Aaron
Copland Ralph Vaughan Williams Virgil
Thompson from write writers John Hersey
and Rupert Brooke and people from the
world of government and politics Indira
Gandhi was recently Tony Blair so it by
way of introducing of all who will speak
to you for a few minutes and and take
questions I'd like to award him with the
Henry Henry Holland Memorial Prize
okay so this is I actually have been
indulging a lot of nostalgia the last
couple of hours because it is going back
to 230 years ago a little bit more I'm
actually impressed at 28 hill house at
the fact that it looks exactly a CD as
it did in 1979 I'm not sure how you do
that you know you do it's like the guys
who have three days stubble all the time
is that something so how do you make a
building neither improve nor deteriorate
any way okay so I'm I really just want
to talk for a little bit I'll talk
economics if politics and everything is
political these days but if politics
comes out fine but let me just talk a
bit about the the economic this amazing
economic situation and I mean that in a
bad way that we're now facing I'm
tempted to well let me commit a little
bit sacrilege you know the Martin Luther
King said I had a dream in my case I had
a nightmare which which was it goes back
about a dozen years we used to in in the
90s there was a period when you had
great faith that at least certain kinds
of economic problems had been solved
that yes there would always be
fluctuations there would be recessions
and and booms but that the really severe
stuff and apically the really persistent
stuff was something that was not going
to happen anymore
the Great Depression had happened but it
had happened because we were ignorant
because people didn't know didn't know
enough about macroeconomics they didn't
understand in particular what the
central bank to do what the Federal
Reserve or the European Central Bank or
its counterparts would do should be
doing and and then a famous actually if
you read my column yesterday and a
famous and now infamous
a set of remarks the current chairman of
the Federal Reserve on the occasion of
Milton Friedman's 90th birthday said
Friedman had said that the Fed failed to
do his job and that's why we had the
Great Depression
so the current chairman of the Fed said
to Milton Friedman you're right we did
it we're very sorry but thanks to you it
won't happen again
well actually by a couple years before
that some of us already we're starting
to have some doubts about whether we
were quite secure in our ability to
prevent something like that from
happening again namely over the issue of
Japan we'll just slid into a slump it
had a big bubble and real estate in the
1980s and when the bubble burst it had a
banking crisis and it never seemed to
recover the they did the usual things
the the Bank of Japan maybe moved a bit
slowly but it did more or less what you
would expect the Federal Reserve to do
it cut interest rates and all of that
and yet the economy stayed depressed
gradually slid into deflation which was
supposed to be something you know it's
it's hard it's hard to stop inflation
because you have to suffer but stop
being deflation can't you just print
money and it turned out that it wasn't
that easy turned out that Japan stuck in
this seemingly endless depressed
economic state and some people did that
and said oh well that just shows how
messed up the Japanese are and and
talked about various you know features
of Japanese institutions and failures of
Japanese policymakers but some people
looked at that and said you know once
you get past the superficial level
Japan's a lot like us yeah they eat more
raw fish and important things that
matter
Japan is a is a big politically stable
advanced economy with lots of room for
maneuver and policymakers who may not be
ideal but aren't idiots and if they can
get caught in that kind of a trap maybe
it could happen to us now when I went to
Princeton and I moved there about ten
years ago there was actually a small
group of Japan warriors we actually had
a kind of a little nest there so there
was myself Mike Woodford who's not a
household name but one of our leading
macroeconomic theorists now
Lars Stenson now gone back to his native
Sweden that to try and help their
central bank deal with the problems and
the fourth guy Bernanke Ben Bernanke
don't know what happened to him all of
who all of us basically very worried by
the Japanese example and by implication
also if Japan was having these problems
you know maybe our view that the Great
Depression was something that could
easily have been prevented wasn't right
either
and so the nightmare was that the United
States and other advanced countries
besides Japan could find ourselves in
this kind of situation an economic
downturn that would not respond that
with that had developed resistance to
the usual antibiotics and that that
would be really hard to deal with on and
the nightmare has come true where we are
now is we are very much in the same
situation if you the difference between
US and Japan in let's say 95 is that
we're actually doing worse that we have
the same sly towards deflation put
numbers lay the numbers on top of one
another and they match almost perfectly
but with much higher unemployment much
more in misery than the Japanese did and
we're finding yet if anything even
harder than Japan did to come to grips
with the problem if we had I think this
has been the surprise to me I'm pretty
cynical and pretty pessimistic but I
never imagined that we would have such a
complete intellectual collapse in the
face of this problem that the the logic
of having the government step in to prop
up demand while the private sector was
unable to spend would be so broadly
rejected that we would be unable to get
enough consensus to do even even a
halfway adequate program of fiscal
policy and now with the only real the
only players with any freedom of
action left is really is the Federal
Reserve it turns out that there's
enormous opposition to them doing
anything as well so what they're doing
is actually in my view like like the
stimulus a step in the right direction
but much too small but they're they're
catching enormous fire for doing even
that and the the level Sarah Palin came
out against quantitative easing
yesterday so this is it's a really
awesome thing that's happening and it
certainly is making at one and and the
economists have turned out to be a
problem and what what Rick Levin is
alluding to here a bit is that we had my
view
Rick's view obviously we had we had a
pretty reasonable view of how the macro
economics worked it was the view that
that we learned from people like Jim
Tobin here it was it wasn't right it's
something that actually if you have that
picture of how things work in your mind
what's going on now is not that hard to
understand but it was a view that was
less rigorous than some people would
like it wasn't derived axiomatically
from first principles and largely for
that reason with perhaps a little bit of
a political under text as well it was a
view that our profession moves steadily
away from over the past thirty plus
years to the point where a lot of
younger economists actually don't even
know any of this stuff they don't even
they can't even as a hypothetical I
can't even do it in the subjunctive
saying well if it were true that the
economy works in the way that Jim Tobin
said it did this is what we should do
they have no idea how to think that way
and so we have we have a complete lack
of a professional of the kind of
professional expertise that might
provide some guidance to the political
process and dealing with all of this so
this point I guess I'm supposed to say
something uplifting and optimistic set
off the discussion
son still comes up in the morning
probably this thing there there there
will something will come along to
improve the situation in the long run
you all know the the most famous quote
in economics from John Maynard Keynes
long run in the long run we are all dead
but but I'm worried because Japan is now
18 years into its version of this and
still stuck and so where it is it is an
amazing thing and personally oh and we
have an election last week we were
probably stalled on policy anyway but
the election pretty much guarantees that
that there will be no policy response
from the US government Europe is also
equally stalled and Japan is pretty much
out of room to do stuff so we actually
have none of the advanced countries able
to able to to respond
the high was on I was on Lehrer news
hour last Friday and had a ok discussion
with with Douglas holtz-eakin who
obviously disagrees with me about a
bunch of stuff but I unfortunately my
best friend Marc came after they stopped
rolling which was I actually had my
solution which is we need to increase
NASA's budget so that we can find
another planet to export to and on that
note why don't I throw it out for
questions
so I'd like to ask undergrads who have a
chance now to ask Walker we've got
microphones at both places you can line
up and let's see what happens
first of all can you please come back to
you sorry I didn't quite get that can
you free can you please come back to you
Oh Italia I did get a little view of the
city and this is not the New Haven I
remember which was really really scuzzy
so I'm not sure it has that feel anymore
okay second in your book Richard's
depression economics do you talk a lot
about the boom-bust cycle you follow
Asia Internet Bob Lowe the updated
version has the housing bubble what are
your views on the proposed bubble in
Treasury bonds and in clean technology
and where do you see that going okay so
for those who don't know this stuff
interest rates are remarkably low right
now and if you're looking at a bond the
price and the interest rate move in
other directions so one way of saying is
the price of US government debt is
remarkably high right now and we just by
the way the opposite of what a lot of
people said was going to happen they
were saying well you know but budget
deficits the government's gonna have to
borrow interest rates gonna go sky-high
and one of the things where I think I
can say that those of us who had that
tobin that MIT Yale access view said got
right was we said that was not going to
happen so then the question is it but
it's that a bubble is that like pets.com
is the US government the equivalent of
pets.com
um and I would say no and I'd say it for
two reasons one is historical again the
Japan example people have been
predicting a crash in Japanese bond
prices and a storage in Japanese
interest rates year after year for 15
years and it never happens Japan even
got downgraded by Moody's and Standard &
Poor's in 2002 and the interest rates
ticked up a little bit and then went
back down again because when you're an
economy that is really depressed
that means that the interest rates that
a social bank can control shortcomings
are going to stay low for a very long
time and if you think the short ones are
gonna stay low or a very long time then
that drags the long rates down unless
you think the country is actually going
to default on its debt which at the
hence countries have an amazing ability
to service depth and in the long run so
it really has to be very extreme for
that to become an issue so and the other
is I'm actually you can actually do the
numbers so this is probably getting way
too wonkish but in the fat and in the
past the behavior of the Federal Reserve
has been pretty well tracked by
something called a Taylor rule which
relates interest rates to unemployment
and inflation right now a Taylor rule
fitted to to pass that behavior says
that the feds target interest rate
should be about minus six percent which
is the problem right there they can't
get below zero but if you take consensus
forecast for the US economy over the
next ten years so you take the
Congressional Budget Office forecast
which I think is way too optimistic but
any we take that in and you say well
what would that say apply a Taylor rule
based on that forecast what short rates
should be over the next ten years which
is that they stay zero for quite a while
and then eventually come back up again
and you ask what ten-year bond rate
would give you the same return as just
rolling over short-term debt I did that
a little while back and it came out at
two point six current interest rates
around two point five five so it's not a
sensible model of you know with a
sensible model combined with what I
think is actually an over optimistic
forecast gives you interest rates in the
vicinity of where we are right now so I
don't see the bubble this is not like
the housing bubble I thought was was but
the clearest thing I'd ever seen in my
life except that somehow nobody believed
it but this one I think is is not a
bubble first of all a little disclaimer
I'm Greek
so my question is on your change and
views of propping up demand via
government demand how do you exactly
suppose governments in Europe US Japan
can do that when they're consistently
penalized by borrowing more from the god
of the markets do you believe that this
goal of the balanced budget is something
that we should be going for or these
that these rating agencies is our only
hampering our ability to increase demand
by debt financing okay so by the way I'm
really Greece has done a lot of damage
not so much because of the not so much
because of the actual consequences of
Greek problems and in a direct sense
because Greece is you know fairly small
part of the European economy but because
of what I think of is that the
hellenization of economic discourse ever
since Greece hit the wall everybody
everybody is been said oh well you know
you mustn't do anything because you'll
turn into Greece and and which you know
is a very very different story Greece is
first of all it was running serious
budget deficits even in good times and
it has a really bad history Greece's
terms I've been in arrears about half
the time since independence so it's you
know it's it's it's not in the same
class as countries like the United
States or the UK or Japan so anyway so
the Greece Greece is that has turned out
to be a really bad influence because
people have taken it to mean that we're
all in that same position now in terms
of what governments can do the way I see
what's going on is that what you have is
a situation in which people borrowed a
lot private sector players borrowed a
lot because housing prices were rising
because it had been a long time since
there'd been a major financial crisis
those of you who if you've read enough
this I basically a Minsky ight now so
there was the kind of heterodox
economists Hyman Minsky who's now
regained a lot of influence posthumously
who said that what you have is these
long cycles in which people get
increasingly optimistic they get they
they start to get very relaxed about
having a lot of debt and then at a
certain point you have what the Minsky
moment or alternatively the wily coyote
moment great if you if you're familiar
with the classics in the in the
Roadrunner cartoons while they call
these ones about five steps off the edge
of the cliff that's when he notices that
there's nothing supporting image so you
get the white amount when people say
suddenly that's too much debt and then
all of the highly indebted players which
is not everybody in the world is forced
into drastic measures to start paying
down debt the trouble is you can't have
which means that they have to spend a
lot less than their income but you can't
have the world as a whole income has to
equal spending so somebody else must
spend more than their income and that's
the role of fiscal policy during this
crisis I mean what you do normally is
you hope that cutting interest rates
persuades people who are not debt
constrained to spend more but interest
rates hit this lower bound to zero and
so there's only so much you can do there
so because you can't do enough of that
you want governments to to spend more
during this period give you a time way
to avoid because if you don't have
somebody else spend more the rest of the
world the non constrained players have
to one way or another spend more than
their income and if you can't raise the
bridge you can't get them to spend more
than you lower the water it the income
Falls you have a world recession so the
role of government spending is to do
this now not everybody can do this
Greece obviously cannot follow a
Keynesian policy Ireland can't follow a
Keynesian policy although it's worth
pointing out that that doesn't mean that
their policies don't have Keynesian
effects these austerity measures that
are being undertaken in Greece in
Ireland and Spain
are further depressing their economies
was getting even worse but the United
States can the United States wants to
borrow money for five years and and
finances it with bonds that are
protected against inflation it can
borrow it at an interest rate right now
of minus 0.5 percent can borrow for 10
years that interest rate of I think only
slightly positive if you take an
inflation-protected bonds there there is
the ability to borrow advanced countries
have have in the past been able to have
pretty high debt burdens without really
getting into into solvency problems so
this is a good time now that's something
you never you you do want to pay the
debt down but you want to do that after
enough people have repaired their
balance sheets to the point where the
private sector can't start spending
again and the problem is that we're not
doing that
so the problem is we're in a situation
where we don't have government spending
monetary policy has has run its course
has run out of room and so it's pretty
grim and but there is really a very very
good case both from history and from
thinking it through for for some death
if we're deficit spending by those
governments that can right now well
Japan has gross debt that's 200 percent
of GDP and it can borrow at about 1
percent interest rates and now is it's
the the a lot of that debt is actually
owned or offset by assets owned by the
the Bank of Japan so be a little bit
Britain Britain had debt that was over a
hundred percent of GDP for about 40
years from the end of World War one
until until the into the 1950s without
ever having a problem so there is some
upper limit but for an advanced country
it's pretty high think the United States
you know that my favorite examples for
for the remarkable ability of advanced
countries to have pretty high debt
levels is his Belgium in Italy both of
which had debt well over a hundred
percent of GDP in the late 1990s without
any kind of solvency crisis and I'd like
those two examples precisely because
they're not strong governments right I
mean this is these are advanced
countries Belgium politically weak
because it's linguistically divided
between the Fleming's and the Walloons
and Italy politically weak because it's
Italy and and yet they were able to have
these high debt levels without a crisis
right people are way it seems to the
markets are entirely sensible markets
are very relaxed about the depth of US
UK Japan it's only if you if you ever
read more of my blog than the columns I
talk about the invisible bond vigilantes
people our parents are constantly being
told you have to appease the bond
digital auntie's the investors who will
go after you for high death and I keep
on saying where are they you're telling
me that we need to be afraid these
people but they exist only in your
imagination well recently in the midterm
elections there's been a lot of pressure
on China for the appreciation of the
Chinese yuan or so my question is what
role does China play in US financial
troubles at the moment and what role
does the valuation of the Chinese remain
be or yuan play in the deflationary
spiral we're facing right now okay so
China is it's keeping the currency
artificially weak that's not really a
question you they have their buying huge
amounts of foreign currency to keep the
the renminbi from from rising and and
they're doing that if they're able to do
that because they have capital controls
so if you if you want to sort of measure
of how far things are
if you would look at at two emerging
markets China and Brazil Brazil there's
been a large rise in the value of the
rail and there should be because money
is cheap and Brazil has good investment
opportunities China is keeping their
currency low they're fighting off
there's actually inflationary pressure
in China because of their undervalued
currency as they're raising interest
rates and restricting credit to stop
inflation while keeping the currency
weak what that does is it means that
China is running an artificial trade
surplus and in normal times you could
say well great they're sending us goods
cheap and they're accepting pieces of
paper from us and so in 2005-2006 you
could say that Chinese were actually
doing us a favor
with their undervalued currency but not
now because now we have a world which is
awash in unemployed workers a world that
has more savings than it knows what to
do with it in a way that's the
definition of our problem and the
Chinese are worsening that problem by
running a surplus that sucks demand away
from the rest of the world so my god
that's referred to Ross Perot and the
great sucking sound but a fair number of
people here were barely born at that
point so but but there really is a great
sucking sound coming from China now
it's probably on the order of around one
percent of gross world product so the
negative that the Chinese are in effect
delivering an anti stimulus to the rest
of us around 1% which is not you know
even if it went away if we made if we
made the Chinese stop doing this it's
not like everything would define but it
contributes to the problems to a
significant degree so that's that's my
view on that it's now if they stopped
doing that what would happen if they
stopped those interventions to keep the
currency weak the currency would rise
how much it would rise what the right
number on the currency is is actually I
mean people will the best estimates say
that it's 25 percent but we have no this
is this is a black art we don't really
quite know what but I think that the
test of it is not what happens to the
currency the test is do they stop buying
many billions of dollars of foreign
exchange every month and that would be
the sign that is happening and
the question is what do you do about it
since they refuse to change that and
that's an interesting thing because if
they were what they're doing is
functionally equivalent to subsidizing
their exports and putting a tax on their
imports it's functionally equivalent to
export subsidies plus tariffs and if
they were doing that then there would be
clear remedy under international trade
law the United States and everybody else
would be entitled to have countervailing
duties as it is the trade law there's
this kind of a just a crack in the trade
law and and this falls right into it so
it's not clear lit quite under the rules
of the WTO what what remedy there is but
I guess I'm at the point where I think
things are bad enough and this is
efficiently I mean this is the most this
is the biggest example of currency
manipulation arguably the biggest
example of it's certainly the biggest
example of currency manipulation in the
history of the world and it's the
biggest protectionist measure because
that's what it amounts to
probably in in the last 60 years so I'm
I'm of the view that the United States
and preferably in in accord with other
countries should say look the the spirit
of the law says this is illegal and
we're going to takes impose sanctions
and I've been trying and trying and
trying to get some someone in in
Washington to someone in the
administration to be willing to actually
move on that I think if this goes on it
will happen you know basically Obama has
no ability to get any legislation
forward on anything if he was wanted to
pass the motherhood and apple pie act
the Republicans would say that
motherhood and apple pie are evil
socialist plots but proposal for trade
sanctions on China would have 80
senators and 380 representatives behind
it so this is something you could do my
question was in 2008 in the run-up
during the presidential campaign
President Obama said you can't have the
same people and expect different results
then as soon as he was sworn into office
we saw a lot of the Clinton economic
team back who had bought into you know a
lot of the policies we're talking about
that kind of led us down over the past
30 years and my guess is that last
Tuesday you didn't see any policymaker
who's really going to swing the tide
come into office so with Larry Summers
and a few others heading out the door it
looks like in the next year or so is
there anyone in the Obama administration
now and the Federal Reserve moving up
through the ranks who I won't go as far
as to say you know lets you sleep at
night but maybe like for a few minutes
you have a momentary like feeling of oh
that's it that isn't yeah I was let me
just say a word about staffing I mean
there was I understand that you wanted
to have people in the administration who
were old hands to some degree were were
were trusted by the mark is that you
know so I now you wouldn't have wanted
to fill all of the ranks of an economic
policy with with with with people from
from more aggressive people on the
liberal side of things but what was
really striking is there were none that
it that I was I was when you looked at
the appointments you're saying okay
where are the people from Economic
Policy Institute which is labor
connected and and you know they they're
they have an agenda they have a position
but they also have good people there so
why isn't you know Larry Michele in the
administration why what they were
essentially there was only one sort of
economist with progressive cred if you
like who was who was brought on and
that's Jared Bernstein who's working for
Joe Biden nobody in the White House
group and that was surprising and maybe
things would have been better if there
had been more of those at this point Wow
I mean I think the I think Ben Bernanke
understands the gravity of the situation
but he's being very cautious and I don't
know whether in his heart of hearts he
people
he should be doing vastly more and but
he's being political or not my guess is
he probably is is pushing as much as he
thinks he can let me tell you I I'm not
sure what I think even now of his job at
the Fed but he was the best department
chairman I've ever had so he probably is
very good on judging the politics but I
think that the vice chairman Yellen is
very good but I think that they have the
trouble is that even with the best of
analysis and intentions there's now so
little room for maneuver that the fiscal
policy proposed even the things that you
would have thought would automatically
happen like maintaining extended
unemployment benefits in the face of
this crisis are actually virtually
impossible politically at the Federal
Reserve anyone who's proposing you know
the kinds of policies that that we were
all talking about as possibilities ten
years ago now has to run a gauntlet of
people within the Fed system who are
worried that that hyperinflation is just
around the corner
so I know actually the answer is I I I
find myself watching old movies too
before I go to bed in order to be able
to sleep at night thank you very talk
professor even I was actually gonna ask
a question about your export strategy to
the moon yeah well I know I mean this is
actually I said something there is it
actually ties in with the last question
but one in a way we do have another
planet which is the emerging world which
is doing much better they're not in this
problem they didn't have a big run-up in
debt they didn't have the housing bubble
and they have inherently because they
are emerging they have lots of
investment opportunities so this zero
lower to the liquidity trap that
afflicts the entire advanced world is
not a problem in and so the emerging
world can to some degree serve as a
locomotive
for the world economy with what tell or
two problems one is that the biggest
player China is is doing its best to
actually push the Train backwards and
the other being that they are still not
that big when all is said and done even
you know there were headlines about
China now being as big an economy as
Japan which is good but it also means
that China is now as big an economy as
Japan and Japan no one would have some
think of Japan as being big enough to be
a locomotive for the world economy but
the closest thing we have to another
planet is in fact the emerging markets
but not big enough got it thank you so I
was just gonna ask you about a
particular emerging market maybe a
testing site for a moon landing South
Korea with President Obama having
mentioned that he wants some kind of a
TA on that just given their increased
efforts at liberalizing their FDI regime
investments going into Korea in the US
but then also the fact that we still
have a current account deficit were some
of the major pros and cons and
ultimately which side would you feel is
the right way for us to work for South
Korea the offer what do I think about
the FTA I guess the question yeah I
don't have strong feelings on it it's
it's probably a good thing but but not
not terribly important in both
directions trade is fairly open as it is
and let's put this way if if I were if I
were advising Obama I would say that
this is not something to spend political
capital on it's not going to make a
significant difference to the u.s.
economic situation it will annoy an
important part of your much shrunken
base don't do it it's just that you look
out world trade negotiations I have to
teach a seminar on world trade on trade
policy most years and it's i alive it is
historical because the fact of the
matter is that we have a world which
with very low trade barriers except in
agriculture and there just isn't that
much at stake I mean
if if the Doha round falls in the forest
and there's nobody to hear it we'll make
a sound I mean if that's where every
note that does this stuff matter very
much I don't think it does and so on the
FTA at this more symbolic and the
trouble is the symbolism would actually
probably be negative for Obama
domestically so you know my advice to
the South Koreans would be you know
don't push it basically so I actually
agree with one of the things you've been
saying probably more repeatedly than
just about anything else which is that
the Obama stimulus package was not big
enough but I've been wondering to what
extent in dollars do you think the
stimulus should have been larger and how
could it have been more effectively
allotted okay so the the measure of it
there's a couple ways to say that the
stimulus wasn't big enough
one is it's simpler than the other so
one is just to say look at government in
America as a whole federal state and
local and ask how much increase in
government spending did we actually get
when all was said and done and the
answer is remarkably little federal
federal sorry government purchases of
goods and services so actually buying
stuff actually grew more slowly over the
past two years than it had in previous
years so we actually we actually
completely failed to deliver any
increase in government spending over
over that over the previous trend that's
because state and local layoffs of
school teachers and suchlike more than
outweighed the little bit of
infrastructure that was in in the in the
stimulus so in that sense the same it
just wasn't enough to stop us from
actually on net having a fiscal policy
that that was contractionary now with
there's some increase in in overall
government spending which is basically
unemployment insurance Medicaid and food
stamps so basically more people fell
into the safety net but that's that's
about all that we con now about the
Obama stimulus one way to look at it is
that we've got an economy that
is running Oh at least 900 billion
dollars a year below capacity and over a
period of several years and yet a
stimulus which over its first two years
delivered about six hundred billion
dollars all stuff so it's just nowhere
near big enough to really match the size
of the of the of the problem plus forty
percent was informed tax cuts which
almost surely were mostly saved rather
than spent another large chunk was in
the form of of aid to state and local
governments which is a good idea but
probably wasn't fully supposed to offset
cuts at the state and local level and
and and did but probably not fully and
the actual if you're looking for the WPA
if you're looking for for the for the
actual things that we think of as
stimulus project it's only about a
hundred billion dollars and it's it's
just not remotely large enough so what
we should have had was something like
1.2 trillion of actual spending actual
building bridges whatever that that
would have been on the scale that would
have really been enough and and there
are South Korea did something like that
big spending of course China did a huge
rapid infrastructure development which
is a little bit easier if you don't have
to actually pass legislation and you
don't worry about corruption but it's a
but that's the kind of thing that the
scale was way short I think there could
have been a lot more infrastructure
spending partly this whole obsession
with shovel-ready we need to get stuff
out quickly was a failure to understand
that slumps that follow financial crises
go on for a very long time so what we
actually have is not the stimulus
actually was was getting doing some
serious stuff late last year and early
this year but it's fading out fast now
and of course that's way premature so
there could have been a lot more so I
would like to be seated to have seen
lots of signs on the roads saying this
this bridge repairs
by the Recovery Act and what you
actually see is a few signs on Amtrak
station saying we're fixing the lights
with money from the Recovery Act but
that's not quite quite as what we what
that's not enough thank you for coming I
would like to say that your theory of
international interstellar trade is one
of my favorite econ papers I was written
by the way in 1978 as a as a frustrated
assistant professor here sitting there
in my in my office in 28th Hill House
where the heat as usual wasn't working
I'm not a huge fan of your call for a
chair fun trot and one of the things
that he says is that China is not a
market economy that the huge state-owned
enterprises that dominate the export
sector have been directed by the central
government to maintain high employment
in the export sector and therefore the
u.s. imposes the chaff that the
state-owned enterprise will simply eat
the loss I was wondering your thoughts
well even if that does happen we've then
we've gotten some revenue for free right
they're just sending us the same stuff
at lower prices and and helping to close
our budget deficit but I gosh I mean I
don't quite a Steve I've been a great
admirer of Steve roaches over the years
I don't understand what he's saying
about us China a lot of it he wants that
he says that the United States needs to
save more which is true but seems to
think that that will somehow solve the
trade problem without something that
gives people incentive to to import less
and export more which which has to be a
movement in the currency there's old
John Williams at the Institute for
International Economics used to have
this great line about people who believe
that you can somehow change trade flows
without actually changing prices that
gives people an incentive to switch what
they're buying and he called that the
doctrine of immaculate transfer and a
lot of what Steve's been saying these
days sounds to me like he's he's fallen
for the doctrine of immaculate transfer
yeah I think this is this is really I
don't understand what what is going to
make what is going to make this harmful
Chinese trade surplus go away unless
unless the exchange rate moves thanks
for coming I'm a freshman and I'm kind
of the one of the reasons that came to
us for that figured I'd be able to ask
people like you might have faked
questions in public and so thank you to
forgive me the shot at I've been reading
your article and I'm also this is
Tacitus and both of you are sufficiently
just making me pessimistic about the
world and economics know that and I'm
kind of wondering whether there's
anything on a microeconomic level to be
done to maybe at least safeguard
ourselves from the kind of collapses
happening around us Wow I I don't
succeed by the ways it's you know it I
think collapse is the wrong word you
want to think of it as being more like a
long a long siege a long period of don't
think about Japan right now Japan
actually in some ways the better social
safety net and and much less open
unemployment than we have so it's it's
in some ways it's it looks better but
you go to if you've gone to Tokyo any
time in you know in the in these 18
years of the Japanese the Lost Decade is
now 18 years long you go in and if
you've gone to Tokyo any time you don't
get the impression of a total disaster
and that's true now if you go to New
York you don't see yeah you know it does
not look like 1933 but it's but it's
still there's an awful lot of pain most
of it out of sight you know there are
things obviously any individual or any
individual company or or after some
extent even even individual states local
governments can try to find ways to to
manage the people will make money
throughout this there will be business
success stories and the other thing I
but this is politically impossible or
more so than getting than getting
adequate
fiscal policy a decent social safety net
makes a huge difference
Europe in terms of GDP the Europeans
have done a little bit worse than we
have actually in this crisis but there's
nothing like the kind of human tragedy
going on in the United States and Europe
because people don't lose their health
care when they lose their jobs because
and in a cases they don't lose their
jobs because there are labor laws that
make that harder to happen then because
there's an adequate system of basic
income even for people who can't find a
job all of the put it this way you Russ
chlorosis they prevent European dynamism
which it was some truth to it they're
not as much Bureau sclerosis is serving
them pretty well in this crisis and and
our highly competitive capitalism red
and tooth and claw markets are a real
disaster in this situation some but you
know individuals it still will be there
will be success stories in business
making their way although it's a good
thing you're a freshman because right
now a graduating senior is facing a
pretty bad market policy decisions do
you think into account the implications
on foreign markets and do you think that
when the Fed announces qe2 they have an
intention to lower exchange rate okay so
this is so on should the Fed be thinking
taking global impacts into account yes
some but you know it is primarily the
Fed is an American institution it's its
primary responsibility is to the US
economy the United States cannot bear
the burden of sustaining the world
economy on its own maybe that was
something you could do 40 years ago but
we're
as everybody says you know there it's a
bigger world now there are more players
um and um so qe2 I'm not sure if
everybody right this is so we've got
quantitative easing which itself is a
terrible phrase because it's a very bad
description of what's happening and now
it's this is supposed to the second
round of quantitative easing and so so
it's all becomes qe2 this is the feds
policy now of buying long-term US
government bonds it is not actually
clear at all that that this policy is
bad for the rest of the world yes it
tends to reduce the US dollars value
which hurts other countries exports and
but on the other hand it to the it also
to some extent expands the US economy
which helps other countries exports and
if you could run through it as a matter
of theory it's definitely ambiguous and
it turns out if you run through it as a
matter of then run the numbers it's it's
ambiguous - nobody is sure enough to
know which whether the net effect on the
rest of the world's economy is positive
or negative but it's not clearly
predatory and no I don't think the Fed
is doing this primarily to weaken the
dollar I think they're doing it because
they're trying to find some traction
anywhere the that's it's supposed to
help housing a little bit supposed to
encourage corporate borrowing it's even
supposed to buy bright driving up asset
values encourage consumer spending it's
it's not a purely exchange rate policy
think about that the contrast with China
people sometimes said well isn't this
the same thing that Chinese are doing no
the Chinese our forces are keeping the
renminbi down while raising interest
rates at home they're they're promoting
exports while choking off the domestic
demand the Fed is trying to push up
domestic demand which has the side
effect of also pushing down the curve
the dollar but it's I think the rest of
the world has I actually the discussion
going on in some of the Econo blogs the
Econo blogging is a great thing we
actually have this really interesting
discussion going on in real time between
smart people but but I've one of the
blog posts I read this morning began
what what is the German
hypocrite which actually turns out to be
quite clear but anyway it's uh but but
it's amazing to see the as as someone
else wrote things actually someone of
that that the Germans are getting really
upset because the United States is
undermining their but they're bigger
than neighbor strategy for recovery so
anyway I'll take one more question with
reference to your metaphor of the
nightmare it seems that we have sort of
an environment of possible deflation
john mack and said on bloomberg
surveillance yesterday that there's a
sharp drop in the money multiplier and
the velocity of money no that shows that
inflation is slowing and possibly
alluding to deflation and there also
seems to be a lack of confidence in the
market where small businesses don't
really know what's gonna happen with
taxes the dodd-frank bill health care so
in that environment and the fact that we
have political gridlock what do you
think some political reform could be
that's the thing it's it's you know if
we hadn't had the filibuster in january
2009 then we might have had a lot more
aggressive policies than we actually had
i mean everything was really dictated by
by what could get those sixty senators
and so that's a political you know if we
do get some reform of the filibuster
which which by the way has changed
enormous lee if people think that they
always used to be the canadian sixty
senators to get anything done and it was
not true used to be at the filibuster
was used on a very sparing basis but but
in since in though increasingly over the
years has become a standard way to block
anything you don't like so the united
states you know it's kind of unique
actually among advanced countries and in
that getting anything done requires a
supermajority so that would have helped
but of course at this point even if you
even if you didn't have require sixty
senators you still have to have economic
policies that Harry Reid and John
Boehner agree on and that's not going to
get you very far
beyond that I don't know I mean I think
the problem at this point is it's not a
simple matter of political institutions
it's a problem of perception and it's
problem of of understanding actually it
was another one of the political
bloggers I was I was reading the other
day said they the the the big we worry a
lot about about gross misunderstand you
were gross
misinformation we worry about people who
who actually believe that the Barack
Obama is a secret Muslim or or that or
that he's spending two hundred million
dollars a day in India or something but
what really damages is the people who
have more softer misinformation who
think that a recession is like a harvest
failure that that that we our ability to
produce has been reduced and therefore
everybody including the government
should tighten their belts and so what
we really need at some level is a
process of Education of getting these
getting some better understanding of the
economic choices out there and which is
hard it is amazing I can say as a
personal reflection to realize how you
can have you can be granted this amazing
thing which is the use of the most
valuable journalistic real estate on the
planet twice a week and still feel
completely powerless to influence public
perceptions which is pretty much way the
way I feel but you know like I say it's
we keep on doing that and we keep on
trying to to to get the story out back
to Keynes
the the if you ever read the Keynes's
general theory the great book
they've concludes with this famous
passage about the importance of ideas
and and I think the last words are in
the long run it is ideas not vested
interests which are dangerous for good
or evil
what he didn't say was whether the ideas
that were dangerous for good reveal and
I'm afraid that evil is winning at the
moment but we keep on trying nice